[Music]
matthew's in buffalo new york hey
matthew how are you
oh i've seen better days but i can't
complain if i'm being honest how are you
doing today better than i deserve sir
how can i help better than i deserve to
i love hearing that i'm a little nervous
um bear with me um i just want to say
thank you mr ramsey and dr john you guys
have helped me um
so much
that you guys won't see the back end of
but emotionally spiritually
financially i want to thank you guys for
all that you do i listen to the youtube
channel all the time almost every single
day thank you how can we help today sir
my question so my question here today is
i have made a giant mistake and i've
neglected um a couple bills and they've
gone to collections and so
well background i'm 19 years old i'm
young i'm stupid and i'm glad i'm making
a mistake today so i'll have to make it
with a bigger mistake later and like i
said these have
bills have gone to collections and
they're about up to eight hundred
dollars
um
and i was wondering if i should
call these collections companies and
get these
um
sorted out through a credit card or
through my debit card because if they go
through and
um overcharge me and it goes through a
credit card it'll be easier to dispute
it with the credit card company versus
the debit card company i've had issues
with both and it's been
fixed with the credit card much easier
than the debit card and getting my money
back so i just want to
get your advice and thoughts on what i
should do where i should start and
that's it so thanks uh for that thank
you what are the bills for what did you
not pay
um so i did not pay um some toll bills
um for like driving over bridges and
that kind of things and like i said
they're up to eight hundred dollars oh
it's all and then you solve that one
thing
yeah it's all one thing over the course
of uh about a year now and i was young
stupid and neglected them okay all right
thank you for taking responsibility yeah
we've all been there man that's a good
that's a good first start for all of us
to take responsibility for what we do in
cause
um
so no i would not use a credit card
because i as you know from i know you're
against credit card i would not have a
credit card so first thing i'll do is
take some scissors and place across that
thing and squeeze hard have plastic
surgery and um
yeah then close that account so okay
that answered that part now the debit
card yeah you're right i would not give
them electronic access to your checking
account which your debit card does do
and so i would not use that to settle a
collection so you were onto something
there what i would do is just find out
the amount
exactly by having a phone call or an
email exchange with the collector
and say all right if i get back on the
phone with you in a few hours
uh what will be the amount
okay
and then go buy a prepaid debit card for
exactly that amount to the penny
and then and then give them that
and then cut that up because it's a
one-time use item
gotcha so what about a money order with
that you could do that too that's fine
or you could do a wire you can do a wire
if you want to as long as they're not
having your debit card or or they don't
have your checking account number
and matthew i even i have a
it's a digital version of this i have a
service that i use that's free it's
online that i put my debit card number
in and it gives me an unlimited number
of
numbers of debit card numbers that i can
use for vendors online and i get to say
what the max payout is so if it gets
taken you can't go any further what's
that called privacy.com okay this is
what i use you can try that is it free
it's free yeah it's fantastic but i put
my number in that way.
do up
privacy.com yeah and i put my debit card
in there and then any of my online
purchases i don't want online companies
having my access to my checking account
and so i can say you can own that any
purchase can only be this much amount
but again there's probably a dozen of
those kind of companies out there and
obviously do your due diligence but
um
like dave said yeah
don't ever give them access to your
account yeah that's the big thing and
you know get in writing it'd be great if
they just send you an email back and say
if you pay by
the 15th of
of march then it'll be this amount and
then you've got that in writing and you
keep keep that in a file in hard copy
and you keep a hard copy of
whatever methodology you used to pay in
the file so this if this ever comes up
again you've got proof that it was all
settled out
and uh the great news is you're now on
top of your money and you're going to
handle things pay your tolls matthew
well done there you go